How about a really, really simple model?
Would you like a really simple model?
Well, of course, you would because who
wants a complicated model if you can
have a simple model?
All right.
Suppose we just start off with a patch,
a location at some point: x, y.
All right.
So, we're going to say, all right.
I've got some patch at x, y, and
my dynamics is going to be random noise.
So what that means is, is that's
the same model that they use for
the head contour.
We're not going to track velocity,
we're just going to assume that
the position changes randomly.
Okay, so as you add your particles
you assume zero velocity so
they stay where they are and
you would add random noise.
And then, how about the very
simplest of sensor models.
Okay, you just take the mean
square difference, right?
So what this says is if I propose that
the state of the object is here, and
it, it used to be here,
I'm just going to compare the patch.
I'm literally going to
subtract the two patches, and
say what's the mean squared error.
Okay?
That would be,
sort of the simplest
sensor model possible.
You could do a slightly more
sophisticated one, right?
You could do a normalized correlation.
You've already learned about
this when we did stereo.
And you could say the higher
the correlation the more likely or
the bigger the sum of the square
differences the less likely.
That would be your simp, sensor model.
So to this,
all you would need is a patch.
So there's a patch.
So those of you who are from
the United States or know U.S.
politics, that's Mitt Romney.
The reason I'm showing you this is
that we provided to the students who
are going to be doing problem sets in,
in the original class I'm going and
the OMS class a video.
Okay?
And this is the patch, grabbed out
of a section of one of the frames.
And your goal is to see with a particle
filter, how long can you track
Mitt Romney until he until it falls
off and he loses the election.